aventuriers de tous âges la ferme de
gally vous lance un défi
arrivé à sortir de ces cinq labyrinthe
de celui fait de grille à celui en
bottes de paille il vous entraîne dans
le monde agricole
il ya un max pédagogique important il ya
un thème autour des vaches des rats
sauvages qu'on peut trouver en france il
ya un tableau concerne toutes les petits
animaux qu'on peut trouver autour de
nous donc ça ce sont des labyrinthes qui
sont destinés principalement aux enfants
on a un espace dédié aux abeilles parce
que agali la prise en compte des
abeilles le respect la protection des
abeilles est quelque chose de très
important notre labyrinthe de céréales
est très tourné autour de l'agriculture
des jeux et des animations qui
s'étendent sur quatre hectares avec un
livret de questions à répondre après
deux mois de confinement de public
familial répond présent très distrayant
bien bien construite
là on a découvert un nouvel endroit
c'est pas pour les enfants profiter du
beau temps les parents ils peuvent aider
parce que c'est quand même un peu
compliqué je trouve ça très très bien ça
permet de voir autre chose sur le
domaine de gally où c'est vrai que c'est
un endroit où vient régulièrement pour
les enfants en ce moment c'est vraiment
l'occasion de retrouver le plaisir de
courir en plein air s'amuser et profiter
de l'extérieur des jeux anciens sont
aussi proposés l'eire 2e accueille du
public tous les jours de la semaine et
tous les samedis de juillet passereaux
en nocturne
il y a comme un air de vacances